Die 2. Bundesliga der Männer biegt auf ihr Saison-Finale ein. Diese verrückte Liga ist natürlich oben wie unten noch überhaupt nicht entschieden. Zusammen mit Matthias Kneifl und Tobias Rieger blicken wir nach dem 27. Spieltag sowohl auf das Aufstiegsrennen als auch auf den Abstiegskampf. Wir beantworten für uns, für wen sieht es gut aus, für wen eher düster. Da gehen wir jetzt rein. Let's go.
Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor.
Und Augsburg ist oben.
Rossi zu kurz Abwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kurt aus dem Bewühm.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Hertha ist auch immer ein gern gesehenes Deppenopfer in solchen Momenten.
Ja, war das nicht sogar gegen Hertha? Stimmt, das war in Berlin, ja genau in Berlin, natürlich. Sonst, ach, das hätte ich viel besser einleiten können, wenn ich mich da noch dran erinnert hätte, naja, egal. Aber du weißt, was ich sagen möchte, wenn man sich mit Standardsituationen beschäftigt, hat man die Möglichkeit, Spiele, die vielleicht einfach nicht so gut laufen, dann noch in seine Richtung zu drehen. Und das war jetzt, glaube ich, so ein Spiel, was Paderborn auch hätte verlieren können. Sie haben es geschafft, sie haben die drei Punkte geholt. Das lag natürlich an Teges, das lag aber auch an den Standards und ein bisschen Glück, dass sie hinten nicht so viele Tore reingekriegt haben. Von daher, ja, Paderborn ist weiterhin oben mit dabei, hat es verpasst, sich richtig abzusetzen, durch die letzten beiden Unentschieden. Und das ist auch ganz gut so.
Ja, ich habe mich auch gefragt, was es bei Paderborn ist. Also zum einen ist es einfach insgesamt eine sehr gute Grundstruktur. Also wenn du dir auch die Saisonstatistiken anguckst, zu herausgespielten Chancen und so weiter, wirst du Paderborn eigentlich überall im oberen Drittel finden, wenn nicht sogar unter den ersten drei. Also sie machen es einfach spielerisch wirklich gut. Und was mir bei Paderborn im Kader gut gefällt, sie haben so viele unterschiedliche Geschmacksrichtungen. Also diese Offensivspieler sind sehr unterschiedlich. Marino, Coppado, Tigges, Ockpala, Bilbia, Michel, das sind alles unterschiedliche Typen. Und dann kannst du je nach Spielsituation halt sagen, okay, Plan A funktioniert nicht, dann Plan B, Steffen Tigges rein, hohe Bälle, Standards, Attacke. So. Und andersrum kannst du es aber auch machen und sagen, hm, heute fehlt uns irgendwie die Tiefe, ja dann wechseln wir Marino ein, der in dem Spiel ja auch eine Chance hatte, die er auf jeden Fall machen muss, das gehört auch zur Geschichte dazu. Aber ich will sagen, ich finde, das sind sehr unterschiedliche Spieler-Typen, die dementsprechend in sehr unterschiedlichen Spielsituationen zum Einsatz kommen können und so hat man eigentlich immer eine Antwort und diese Mischung aus Stabilität und Flexibilität, die gibt es in dieser Liga selten bis gar nicht. Also ich finde, Paderborn zeichnet sich gar nicht unbedingt vielleicht auch immer durch diesen einen Stil aus, sondern durch mehrere und die beherrschen sie aber alle gut. Und das ist über Jahre jetzt durch verschiedene Trainer, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen angereichert worden, dass jeder auch so ein bisschen was reingegeben hat. Und ich finde, also für mich würde es sehr wundern, wenn Paderborn in den nächsten Spielen abreißen lässt. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Sie spielen gegen Fürth als nächstes, danach gegen Magdeburg und danach gegen Hannover. Alles Teams. Und danach spielen sie noch gegen alles von oben. Das muss man im Gesamtkontext auch sagen. Da sind wir wieder. Aber ich glaube, du siehst es ja, Paderborn ist einfach unglaublich schwer zu schlagen. Und das wird sie bis zum Ende oben halten. Da bin ich ganz fest von überzeugt. Matthias, bitte.
Ja, wir hatten ja in der Hinrunde die Situation, dass Paderborn auch schon fast vorne ein bisschen weg ablopiert war. Und da zum Ende der Hinrunde eingebrochen ist jetzt vielleicht ein hartes Wort. Aber sie haben zumindest die anderen aufschließen lassen und haben da noch Federn gelassen. Und ich glaube, genau das wird ihnen nicht noch mal passieren. Ich glaube, die werden aus dieser Hinrunde ihre Lern ziehen und dann auch mehr Punkte sammeln und deshalb auch bis zum Schluss ein Faktor sein im Ausstiegsrennen. Und gerade dieses Spiel gegen Dresden hat auch mich ein bisschen vom Ausgang her betrübt. Natürlich, das ist ein direkter Kontrahent, den hätte man gerne Federn lassen sehen. Aber gerade die erste Halbzeit, da wirken sie für mich etwas ratlos, wie sie selbst ein Offensivspiel aufziehen gegen ein starkes oder ein gefestigtes Dresden, wie sie die wirklich beschäftigen und unter Druck setzen können. Und dann hatten sie es ja doch geschafft mit Anpassungen, mit Moral und auch dem richtigen Joker mit dem Hinterkopf des Spieltags sozusagen, Tickets mit zweimal Kopfballverlängerung ins Tor und dem notwendigen Glück. Und ich glaube, das sind einige Zutaten, die brauchst du einfach, wenn du oben dranbleiben willst und mitmischen willst. Und deshalb wirken die in Summe für mich auch gefestigt. Und ich bin gespannt, wie jetzt das zu verstehen ist, dass, wenn ich es richtig aufgeschnappt habe, das Team jetzt eine Woche frei hat. Also, Kettemann geht den irgendwie eine Woche frei. Also, interessanter Move. Kann aber auch die Köpfe nochmal anders frei bekommen und dann für den Endspurt wappnen lassen. Also, auch da gehen sie interessante Wege.
Ich denke, es ist immer, wie du es machst, machst du es falsch oder richtig. Am Ende kannst du sagen, genau deswegen hat es geklappt oder nicht geklappt. Das ist immer schwer zu beurteilen im Nachhinein. Aber nachdem du jetzt auch nochmal die Leistung von Dresden kurz angesprochen hast, würde ich sagen, gehen wir da jetzt genau hin. Denn Dynamo ist das besiegte Team in diesem Spiel, aber muss vielleicht gar nicht so das Betrübte sein. Zumindest ich von außen wäre nicht so betrübt, denn das ist eigentlich eine mutmachende Leistung gewesen, so aufzutreten. Ich fand es wieder sehr gut und es steht im Zeichen einer Dresdner Mannschaft, die nach Hannover, glaube ich, die rückrundenstärkste Mannschaft ist, die im Winter sehr viele Dinge richtig angegangen ist in den Neuverpflichtungen. Die individuelle Qualität noch mal nach oben geschraubt. Erkannt, es liegt nicht am Trainer. Wir müssen da nichts strukturell verändern, sondern es sind die immer wieder vermalledeiten individuellen Fehler in der Defensive. Ist das mangelnde Effizienz nach vorne vielleicht? Da müssen wir vielleicht was tun. Und das haben sie getan. Und seitdem läuft die Nummer wirklich für einen Abschlusskandidaten bemerkenswert gut. Wirklich gute Spiele in Paderborn gemacht. Auch da, wie gesagt, nur mangelnde Effizienz. Und Tim Schreiber, ich glaube, das ist das Einzige, was man sich da kollektiv wie individuell vorwerfen kann. Ansonsten stimmt da so viel. Es ist erst die zweite Niederlage im neuen Jahr. In den zehn Spielen insgesamt hat man 16 Punkte geholt. Darunter dieses 6-0-Freak-Ergebnis gegen Münster. Klar, die sicherlich auseinandergefallen sind. Muss aber auch erst mal sechs Tore schießen, in der Situation, in der sich Dresden befindet. Und die nächsten drei Gegner, finde ich, machen durchaus Mut. Das sind Hertha, Nürnberg und Bochum. Da kann man definitiv in der Situation, in der sich Dresden, finde ich, befindet oder in der Form, in der man sich befindet, definitiv was mitnehmen. Ich will sie noch nicht aus dem Abschließsampf rausreden, aber Tobi, würdest du da mitgehen, zu sagen, um die muss man sich fast am wenigsten Sorgen machen?
Absolut. Genau so habe ich es aufgeschrieben. Um die mache ich mir im Moment zumindest am wenigsten Sorgen. Wir wissen alle, der Blick nach hinten hilft nicht immer bei dem Blick nach vorne, aber ich wüsste nicht, was Dresden jetzt noch so in Straucheln bringt, dass sie das vermasseln. Also die hatten 13 Punkte nach der Hinrunde. Das war ganz, ganz gruselig. Die hatten schon 4 Punkte Rückstand auf die Relegation und haben sich dann, wie du es gerade beschrieben hast, mit einem Weg gefangen, der vielleicht tatsächlich, den Trainer zu behalten, gar nicht so gewöhnlich ist und dementsprechend dann auch gerne mal belohnt werden darf. Ich bin ehrlich, ich habe es nicht so richtig verfolgt zum Start der Rückrunde und war deshalb etwas überrascht, als sie bei Hannover einen Punkt holten, am dann bereits 23. Spieltag. Davor hatten sie gegen Ebersberg verloren, gegen Schalke unentschieden. Ich erinnere mich auch noch, dass sie da auf Schalke relativ viel Ramazanma noch gemacht haben hinten raus. Und dann hörten sie aber nicht auf, weil sie dann auf einmal gegen Darmstadt auch noch gewonnen und 3-3 gegen Karlsruhe. Okay, auch eine wilde Geschichte. Was für das Torverhältnis getan haben, auch das ist ja auch nicht ganz unwichtig, gerade wenn das da unten so eng ist, wie es ist in der Tabelle. Ich wüsste nicht, warum Dynamo Dresden noch mal in Argeprobleme mit dem Abstieg kommen sollte. Also wie gesagt, gegen Hannover fand ich es nicht schön, wie sie gespielt haben. Das war ein sehr ruppiges, sehr körperbedrohtes Spiel, aber wahrscheinlich das beste Mittel gegen uns in der Situation und von daher auch völlig legitim. Brauche ich nicht drüber zu reden. Das ist aber nicht deren Standardfußball. Das ist eigentlich das Schöne, dass sie dann auch zeigen können, sie können es gegen die Mannschaften, die relativ weit oben in der Tabelle stehen, aber sie sind auch in der Lage, gegen Mannschaften, die weiter unten stehen, dann wirklich zu überzeugen. Und wenn es ein Freak-Spiel ist, ist es ein Freak-Spiel. Aber so hast du trotzdem gewonnen gegen Preußen Münster und hast das auch völlig verdient getan. Und so bringst du dann ja die großen Abstände da rein. Ich denke, Dynamo Dresden ist zu den Mannschaften zu zählen, die es geschafft haben. Oder, Matthias?
Ja, ich denke ja auch, dass Dresden jetzt nicht auf die Idee kommt, zu glauben, das wird ein Selbstläufer.
Nein, das ist ein Punkt auf Platz 16.
Ja, genau. Also gerade die Situation, Tobi, du hast es erzählt, diese da ferner Chance, die ja das 2 zu 0 beleuchtet hätte, also einen freien Abschluss vor dem Tor hatte, da hat ja Stamm auf der Außenlinie quasi sich umgetreten und gegen die Kabine getreten. Also ich glaube, der ist so on fire, dass er seinem Team jeglichen Schlendrianen, falls auch immer der überhaupt irgendwo nur Anzeichen zeigen sollte, den austreiben wird. Deshalb bin ich guter Dinge, dass die wissen, worauf es ankommt, dass sie jetzt ihren Lauf fortsetzen können. Zumindest, dass sie nicht plötzlich abreißen lassen und plötzlich noch mal unten– na klar, sie sind unten drin, aber noch mal richtig unten rein rutschen. Insofern, die wirken– also im Endeffekt haben sie für mich anhand der mangelnden Chancenverwertung gerade den Sieg gestern liegen lassen. Die hätten schnell den Daumen drauf haben können, wie Tobi sagte. Und deshalb sind auch, was wiederum auch Tobi sagte, mit Standards erfolgreich. Also die wissen auch, dass sie solche Chancen nutzen können, wie eben beim 1 zu 0. Ich glaube, das war eines der wenigen, wenn nicht sogar das erste Standardgegentor von Paderborn. Also auch da interessante Statistik. Und gucken wir mal, was die nächsten Wochen bringen. Aber Dresden ist für mich auch schon weiter auf dem Weg nach vorne gewesen, als es punkttechnisch bislang sind.
Ja, weil sie eben zu viel aufholen mussten. Aber ich finde, das ist so ein positiver Drive in der Mannschaft, einfach wenn man sich anguckt, wer geht denn jetzt mit einer guten Form ins Saisonfinale und da hast du bei Dresden einen Fermee, der richtig gut aussieht. Du hast einen Hauptmann, der extrem gut aussieht, ein toller Antreiber im Mittelfeld. Du hast diese Neuzugänge, die jetzt auf Spielzeit kommen. Also ein Robert Wagner macht es gut. Ein Keller war jetzt krank in Paderborn. Vielleicht auch ein Faktor, warum es am Ende vielleicht die letzten Prozente nicht gereicht haben, weil auch der war ja auf Anhieb. Ein super Neuzugang, Ben Bobzin, der beste Name der 2. Liga, ist jetzt schon richtig wichtig für diese Mannschaft. Bringt da richtig Drive über den linken Flügel rein. Also ich finde, allein mit welcher Form gewisse Einzelspieler in die letzte Saisonphase gehen, da hat Dresden richtig was drin. Schäker finde ich, ja, es ist typisch Schäker. Das ist Jason Schäker, der ist mal so, mal so. Mal geht er komplett unter, mal siehst du, boah, feiner Fußballer. Also ist mal so, mal so. Aber auch der funktioniert. Also dementsprechend finde ich schon, dass das eine richtig gute Aussicht ist, die Dresden jetzt in den letzten Spielen hat. So gut eine Aussicht da im erbitterten Abschiedskampf eben sein kann. Man will es ja auch nicht zu zu blumig reden. Das wollen wir auf jeden Fall vermeiden. Blumig wird es oft eher, wenn wir nach oben gucken. Und ich finde, da kommen wir jetzt auch an. Wir blicken nämlich auf das Topspiel dieses Spieltags. Das war das Spiel zwischen Darmstadt und Schalke. Die trennen sich am Ende eins zu eins. Und Matthias, wir haben hier mit dir den Lilien-Experten. Blicken wir mal zuerst auf das Heimteam. Blicken wir auf Darmstadt. Wie würdest du diese Leistung bewerten?
Ja, vielleicht ganz grundsätzlich. Es wurde ja viel angepriesen im Vorfeld. Das Topspiel, 1. gegen 2, 2 Teams, die versuchen, den Aufstieg klarzumachen. Da war es wahrscheinlich für den neutralen Beobachter gestern eher jetzt nicht so ein Highlight-Spiel. Gleichwohl war es ein sehr packendes Spiel, für mich zumindest im Stadion selbst. Und ich hatte vor kurzem ein Interview mit Michael Klefisch fürs Stadionmagazin. Und da meinte er zu mir, ganz unabhängig jetzt von dem Spiel gegen Schalke, dass es immer darum geht, in einem Spiel den Gegner Aufgaben zu stellen. Und ich finde, das hat Schalke sehr gut gemacht. Weil sie haben von Anfang an den Daumen auf dem Spiel gehabt, um mal wieder das Körperteil ins Spiel zu bringen. Also haben hochgepresst, haben das Aufbauspiel gestört. Darmstadt war gezwungen, die langen Bälle zu suchen oder die Seitenverlagerung über die Flugbälle, prima durch Pfeiffer. Es war ein ungemein physisches Spiel, dass dann schlussendlich zwei Standards auch für die Einzelnen oder die einzigen Tore sorgen, war vielleicht so ein bisschen symptomatisch. Aber ich finde schon, wenn man als Ligen-Fan vielleicht ins Spiel gegangen ist, boah, wir haben hier von 13 Heimspielen 10 gewonnen und 3 unentschieden. Es ist alles bereitet. Wir haben das Pokalspiel gegen Schalke 4-0 gewonnen. Das wird ein Fest. Das war vielleicht ein Trugschluss. Also Schalke hat wirklich von Beginn an klar gemacht, das Spiel wird über sie entschieden und sie haben da einen guten Zugriff auf das Spiel. Und Darmstadt hat es dann peu à peu verstanden, sich ein bisschen besser darauf einzustellen. In der zweiten Hälfte dann noch besser als im Laufe der ersten Halbzeit. Und Schalke hatte durchaus einige Abschlusschancen, die auch zu Toren hätten führen können. Und ein intensives Spiel, ein taktisches Spiel. Zwei Teams, die aber auch gezeigt haben, dass sie zurecht, finde ich, da oben stehen. Und dass die Trainer vielleicht auch einigermaßen einverstanden waren mit dem, was sie sehen konnten, waren die Wechsel. Also Marseille, verletzungsbedingt eben der Wechsel in der ersten Halbzeit. Aber ansonsten gab es nur jeweils zwei Doppelwechsel, nämlich Schalke in der 79. und Darmstadt in der 83. Wenn du so wenig von außen ins Spiel eingreifst, dann bist du mit dem, wie das Spiel sich entwickelt, doch einverstanden. Also sprich, dann konnte entweder das Team das umsetzen, was du ihm mit auf den Weg gegeben hast, oder das Team hat es verstanden, besser ins Spiel zu kommen, als es vielleicht von Anfang an absehbar war. Und Darmstadt wurde ja durchaus auch schon nachgesagt im Laufe der Saison, dass es durchaus auch einen Plan B im Köcher hat, wenn mal der Plan A nicht so funktioniert. Also Hannover das Hinspiel. Tobi, wenn wir uns erinnern, in der ersten Halbzeit ging es bei Darmstadt in Führung, aber hätte dann abgeschossen werden können, schon fast im Zuge der ersten Halbzeit. Und hat es dann in der zweiten Halbzeit wiederum verstanden, zurückzukommen und dann auch den Deckel draufzumachen. Also es war vielleicht so ein idealkypisches Spiel, wie es Darmstadt doch immer wieder versteht, Rückstände zu egalisieren oder sogar noch umzudrehen. Und gerade zu Hause sind sie an der Stelle einfach mit einem gewissen Selbstverständnis gesegnet, das ist dann auch so eine Aufgabe, wie es Schalke gestern gestellt hat, zumindest in dem Unentschieden münden zu lassen. Das wäre mal so mein Take auf dieses Spiel gezogen.
Mir fiel, während ich das Spiel geguckt habe, also ein Wort war einfach sehr präsent, das haben wir heute schon bei Paderborn fallen lassen, Stabilität. Also wenn du– Schalke gehörte definitiv die Anfangsphase der Partie, super aggressiv gepresst, erste Torannäherung gehabt, auch wenn noch nicht super zwingend, aber es gab ja zum Beispiel diese Karamann-Chance. Aber wie gesagt, vor allen Dingen gegen den Ball hat man Darmstadt fast aufgefressen. Darmstadt hat das kaum geschafft, mal den Ball laufen zu lassen, was ja Darmstadt durchaus auch im eigenen Spiel aufbauen möchte. Also das ist jetzt eigentlich gar nicht idealtypisch. Leadback kann man in Tief zu schicken mit den Bällen, auch wenn das sicherlich eine Wahl sein kann. Also dann kommst du sogar, fände ich, nach dieser Anfangsviertelstunde ein bisschen besser an die Partie durch diesen auch abgeerkannten Treffer. Und dann zack, genau in diese Phase kommt dieser Schock mit Luca Marseiler. Schwere Verletzungen, du siehst sofort, verdacht auf Kreuzbandriss, Schubladentest, der ist sofort am Boden zerstört, alle drum herum. Ich meine, Florian Kohfeldt sagte nach der Partie, dass einige Mitspieler sofort auch Tränen in den Augen hatten, weil zum einen, weil sie verstanden haben, was da passiert sein könnte, zum anderen, weil Luca Marseiler so eine wichtige Rolle in diesem Team, an dem sich sehr gesteigert hat, wichtiger Spieler geworden ist. Diese Verletzung bricht dann ja auch ein bisschen den Rhythmus der Partie, finde ich. Also danach wird es ein bisschen ausgeglichener, ein bisschen zerfahrener auch. Dann kassierst du auch noch das 0 zu 1. Also bis dahin ist wirklich nicht viel für Darmstadt gelaufen. Und dann bist du aber einmal da, weil du in der Nachspielzeit der ersten Halbzeit den Ausgleichstreffer zielst. Klar, ein studierter Variante, auf einem langen Fossen quasi. Pfeiffer setzt sich da im Kopfballspiel durch, weil es ist halt Pfeiffer, riesig. Und dann macht das Liedberg wirklich fantastisch. Das ist einfach eine fantastische individuelle Stürmerleistung. So, das macht ein Liedberg einfach. Da sind wir wieder bei individueller Qualität, die einigen Teams auch fehlt auf dieser Position. Und dann gehst du mit dem 1-2-1 in die Halbzeit und kannst dich damit auch glücklich schätzen. So, die Halbzeit ist dann tendenziell eher bei Darmstadt. So, mehr Spielkontrolle. Gleichzeitig, finde ich, hast du beiden Teams angemerkt, sie sind mit sich selber zufrieden. Ja, sie sind aber auch mit dem Ergebnis zufrieden. Sie haben gar keinen Drang, das Gefühl, das Aufstiegsrennen an dem Spieltag entscheiden zu müssen. Punkt für beide, okay, dann werden wir unsere Punkte vielleicht, unsere drei Punkte woanders vielleicht noch holen. Also ich fand schon, dass zum Ende hin jetzt kein Team volles Risiko gegangen ist auf Schalker Seite, muss man aber schon erwähnen. Gummis in der 84. Eieieieieieieieiei. Also der wird auch wirklich nicht mehr zum Goalgetter. Das Ding musst du mindestens aufs Tor bringen, wahrscheinlich sogar im Tor unterbringen. Sei es drum, am Ende finde ich ein Unentschieden, wo Schalke die Nasenspitze weiter vorne war, aufgrund der ersten Halbzeit vielleicht und aufgrund dieser Last-Minute-Chance von Gummis. Aber insgesamt ein Spiel, was völlig leistungsgerecht ist, was die Qualität beider Teams– wie ist das denn Respekt beider Teams– füreinander, finde ich auch. Und von daher, Tobi, vielleicht letzte Worte zu Darmstadt. Auch da der Eindruck, die sind zu stabil, als dass sie abreißen lassen werden zum Ende hin.
Ja, ich hatte das Gefühl, sie hatten im Laufe der Saison oder auch der Rückrunde war es mehr so ein bisschen Phasen, wo sie vielleicht auch ein bisschen sich durchgeglückt haben durch die Spiele. Das konnte man jetzt gegen Schalke auf gar keinen Fall sagen. Also das war in dem einen oder anderen Spiel kam es mir so vor, als ich nicht mal dachte, ach guck mal, Darmstadt, jetzt lassen sie Punkte. Ach nee, scheiße, doch nicht.
Ja, das war zum Beispiel gegen Hertha der Fall.
Genau, solche Spiele hatte ich von Darmstadt gefühlt öfter gesehen. Vielleicht drehen wir es so, wie Matthias es gesagt hat, und sagen, dann hat man sich nochmal angepasst und das Spiel hinten raus nochmal durch Umstellung besser gestaltet. Am Ende egal, es gab zwei Sachen, die ich noch gerne ergänzen bzw. bekräftigen wollte. Einmal das, was Matthias gesagt hat. Dass Schalke so ein Spiel nicht aus der Hand gibt, dass Schalke so ein Spiel dominiert. Das Gefühl hatte ich, als wir da waren, auch komplett. Also, die wissen, was sie tun. Die haben so ein Spiel, ja, die haben so einen Daumen drauf aus so einem Spiel und lassen den Gegner da nicht anfangen, irgendwelche wilden Ideen durchzusetzen. Das können die sehr, sehr gut. Und das liegt natürlich. Und jetzt eigentlich wollte ich ihm einen Spruch drücken, weil er, also der Trainer von Schalke, Miro Music, weil er gegen 96 in der 96. Minute, als der Ball ins Aus gekloppt war, so schön gejubelt hat und dann auch noch das 2-2 kriegt. Aber den Spruch spare ich mir und sage stattdessen, dass das einfach ein richtig feiner Typ ist, so wie er in der Pressekonferenz begonnen hat und sich allen voran um Luca Marseila. Also ihm war das Spiel egal. Erstmal war es wichtiger zu sagen, dass ihm das sehr leid tut und beste Genesungswünsche ausricht. Und das, finde ich, darf man auch immer nicht vergessen. Da ist ein Spieler, der keine leichte Karriere hatte. Ich glaube, in Haching war der auch schon nicht mehr verletzt als gesund. Aber auf jeden Fall hat er viele, viele gesundheitliche Probleme gehabt. Und wenn der Trainer des Gegners so etwas weiß und das zum Eröffnen der Pressekonferenz einfließen lässt und sagt, das ist eine stabile Nummer, das wollte ich noch mal hervorheben. Das Spiel selber habe ich mir gestern Abend tatsächlich geklemmt. Deshalb hat Matthias das, glaube ich, allumfassend zusammengefasst und Marc fantastisch ergänzt. Deshalb habe ich jetzt nur die beiden Blümchen links und rechts noch gestreut.
Die beiden Lilien, meinst du? Die beiden Lilien.
Nein, nein, nein.
Es gibt ja auch tatsächlich, glaube ich, eine gegenseitige Wertschätzung, was so in den PKs runden das Spiel klar wurde von Kohfeldt und Muslitsch, dass sie beide hervorgehoben haben, wenn sie sich den Gegner anschauen und analysieren, dass man da eine klare Handschrift sieht und dass man es mit Teams zu tun hat und nicht mit starken Mannschaftsteilen oder sowas, sondern dass beide erkennen, was der gegnerische Trainer und das gegnerische Team auf den Platz bringen. Und deshalb war für mich, das gestern auch fast schon idealtypisch, dass es dann so sich irgendwann neutralisiert hat. Und vielleicht dann beide auch im Schluss mit dem Unterschied einverstanden waren und lieber den Punkt mitnehmen, als noch irgendwas zu riskieren, selbst wenn Gummis diese Riesenchance hatte. Und gerade Schalke, wenn ich mir vor Augen führe, die Spiele in der Hinrunde, Niederlage auf Schalke, Heimspiel 4 zu 0, dann im Pokal. Das Schalke von damals ist nicht mehr das von heute, finde ich. Also es ist nochmal deutlich gefestigter. Es hat qualitativ an Substanz gewonnen, selbst wenn jetzt Cecho nicht dabei war. Aber alleine, wenn du siehst, dass eben mit, jetzt fehlt mir der, von Köln, der Österreicher. Genau, danke. Der war jetzt gestern nicht so auffällig, hat ja aber durchaus auch ein Tor machen können, auch Auschisch. Also das sind schon Spieler, die dem Spiel was geben, die eine Breite geben. Und Schalke hat auch durchaus Verletzungssorgen. Das heißt, da konnte man wiederum was auffangen. Also wir haben kein Christopher-Anthia-Jay gerade am Start, auch Vitaly Becker fällt aus. Heul und Lassme, ein Peter Remmert aus dem Hinspiel gegen Hertha. In der Form, der auf jedes Spiel gewinnt, weil er einfach alles in Grund und Boden läuft. Und auch Schalke ist nicht frei von Sorgen, aber sie schaffen es durch die Ergänzungen in der Winterpause hervorragend mit den richtigen Stellschrauben, die sie gedreht haben, jetzt so eine Rolle zu spielen. Und gleichwohl, Schalke ist, glaube ich, seit dem siebten Spieltag unter den besten Zweien, also immer auch durchgängig auf dem Ausstiegsplatz. Jetzt, wo es so zusammengerückt ist, das Feld, können sie irgendwann auch plötzlich nur noch Vierter sein. Und da bin ich mal gespannt, was das macht mit Schalke. Aber ich sehe sie wirklich als Team, als gefestigtes Team, das mir signalisiert, der Ausstieg geht über diese Mannschaft. Und jetzt hat Darmstadt natürlich noch einige Heimspiele vor der Brust gegen direkte Kontrahenten. Auch da, die werden das Zünglein an der Waage sein. Und Darmstadt muss jetzt gucken, dass sie den Ausfall von Marseila wegstecken, der einfach einem Spiel auch über die Außengeschwindigkeit gibt, der ein Tripling-Faktor ist, den du so in dem Maße nicht so sehr mehr hast im Kader. Du hast Corridor, der aber auch aus einer längeren Verletzungsphase kommt. Du hast jetzt wieder Hornby auf ihn zurückgreifen können, der aber auch vier Wochen nicht am Stadt war. Da hat er auch Kofeld vor dem Spiel angekündigt. Sie werden jetzt einen Wechsel machen in ihrer Hangehensweise. Bislang war es in der Saison die Prämisse, wenn jemand verletzt ist, würde er erst wieder eingesetzt, wenn wir sichergehen können, er ist nicht gleich wieder in Erfolgeverletzung, sofern du das irgendwie kannst. Und jetzt ist es die Prämisse, sobald jemand fit ist, spielt er. Also sie wollen jetzt nicht mehr die Profilaxe, sondern sie wollen die Einsatzfähigkeit an der Stelle haben. Ich hatte vorhin schon darauf hingewiesen, auswärts schwächeln sie. Sie spielen in Summe auch ein bisschen zu viel Remis inzwischen. Was zwar schön ist, dass du nicht verlierst, aber sie gibt es halt immer noch zwei Punkte mehr als ein Unentschieden. Und sie haben langsam auch dann die Auswärtsspiele gegen Abstiegskandidaten. Da hat man auch schon gesagt, das wird kein Selbstläufer. Und langsam haben sie auch ein paar gelb vorbelastete Spieler. Also vier gelbe Karten haben wir inzwischen. Hornby, Kläfisch, Liedberg, Marseille– okay, ist jetzt kein Faktor mehr– und Vukotic. Das bedeutet, auch da können in entscheidenden Saisonphasen Spieler fehlen, die wehtun. Haben sie zuletzt aber auch schon. Sie haben es kompensieren können. Aber um das Ganze ein bisschen abzurunden. Darmstadt ist im Stande, in Spielen verschiedene Systeme zu fahren, sei es Ballbesitz, sei es Umschaltspiel, sei es hinter die Kette. Das Einzige, was Kohfeldt für sein Team nicht in Anspruch nimmt, sind zweite Bälle. Da wollen sie nicht so drauf setzen. Das ist jetzt nicht das, was ihr Repertoire per se ausmachen sollte. Aber sie haben jetzt einfach auch ein Team bei Sam, das weiß, wie sie zusammen funktionieren. Ergänzt durch Schmidt in der Winterpause auch mit einem gewissen Faktor, der sehr technisch versiert ist und im Angriffsspiel was geben kann. Und insofern, geile zweite Liga. Du hast fünf Spitzen-Teams, die wirklich Teams sind, die Gegner manchmal zynisch besiegen, oft genug aber auch kleine Schranken weisen können, ohne dass es jetzt ergebnistechnisch ein Kantersieg wird, aber einfach ein sicherer Sieg. Und da können wir uns wirklich auf die Endphase freuen.
Es ist einfach so Wahnsinn, was diese Terminplanung… Weiß natürlich keiner vorher. Und ich bin mir auch sehr sicher, dass bei der DFL keiner gesessen hat, gesagt hat, es wären ja Elbersberg, Darmstadt, Hannover…
Dieses Mastermind möchte ich kennenlernen.
Die müssen wir hinten raus. Schalke muss natürlich auch noch gegen fast alle spielen, weil sonst würde sich das nicht ausgehen. Die haben jetzt natürlich Hannover und Darmstadt hinter sich gebracht und haben dann die beiden Auswärtsspiele in Elbersberg und Paderborn. Das ist Wahnsinn. Also da ist alles noch drin und…
Es ist Geld, einfach bis zum Ende in dieser Verlosung drin zu bleiben. Das ist wirklich die Prämisse. Alles andere kannst du gefühlt nicht mehr einfassen. Auch bei den vielen direkten Duellen, das ist einfach nicht absehbar, nicht berechenbar. Um Darmstadt und Schalke einmal zu beenden, Darmstadt 50 Punkte, Rang 4 aktuell. Die nächsten drei Spiele sind Bielefeld, Hannover und Fürth. Wir haben aber, wie gesagt, auch noch Elversberg und Paderborn zu Hause. Schalke steht mit 52 Punkten auf Rang 1. Die nächsten drei Spiele sind der KSC, Elversberg und Münster. Ich möchte noch mal unterstreichen, was du gesagt hast, Matthias. Der Aufstieg wird nur über Schalke gehen. Ich leg mich hier mehr oder weniger auch schon fest. Ich glaube, die gehen hoch. Ich sehe es nicht. Auch durch diesen Push, den sie im Winter durch die Neuzugänge bekommen haben, diese Variabilität. Ich finde, du hast in diesem Spiel schon gemerkt, dass einen Edin Dzeko gefehlt hat, weil diese Anschlussstation ein bisschen gefehlt hat. Zilla ist einfach ein anderer Spielertyp und er kriegt dann diese tiefe gegen so gute, defensiv gute Gegner nicht rein. Ja, er war bei der einen Ecke dann da und das ist dann auch das Knipsergehen, das ist ja auch gut. Aber ich glaube, mit Dzeko wäre es noch mal ein anderes Spiel gewesen, weil er die Verteidigung ein bisschen anders beschäftigt hätte durch seine Physis, durch seine Cleverness gegen den Ball, mit Ball. Das hat Schalke ein Stück weit gefehlt und etwas zahnloser gemacht. Trotzdem wurde ja die Sperre reduziert. Das ist anscheinend auch möglich, war bei Hertha und Kufnatsky nicht möglich. Es ist alles eine super eigenartige Linie seitens des DFB. Aber sei es drum, darum soll es jetzt nicht gehen.
Und sie haben vielleicht ihren Durchhänger auch schon hinter sich. Die hatten ja zum Beginn der Rückrunde, als alles rund um Dzeko gehypt war, da hatten sie die Ergebnisse nicht so in Serie.
Und die Runde der Rückrunde mit diesem Spiel gegen Braunschweig war schon nicht gut.
Genau. Richtig. Und vielleicht haben sie sich da jetzt die Auszeit in Anführungszeichen schon genommen. Aber auch der Entspurt wird eine Nerven-Sache. Wer hat dann, wenn es drauf ankommt in der Crunch-Time, wer kriegt die Flatter oder wer ist gefestigt?
Wer ist gefestigt? Und da sind diese riesigen Fan-Massen von Traditionsvereinen ja auch immer Fluch und Segen zugleich. Das kann eine Wucht entwickeln, die kein anderer Verein entwickeln kann. Das kann ich aber auch unter Druck setzen, wie nirgendwo anders. Also Standortfaktor, sicherlich auch noch eine zum Ende hin. Und dementsprechend gehen wir jetzt dann auch weiter, denn das Spiel ist zu Ende erzählt. Und wir kommen zu einem Spiel– wo habe ich es denn genau? wo jetzt kein Team mehr von oben beteiligt war, denn das ist das Spiel Fird gegen den KSC. Fird verliert gegen den KSC nach zuletzt zehn Punkten aus vier Spielen. Das war dieses beeindruckende Fird, was Tobi schon erwähnt hat, wo keiner wusste, woher das jetzt eigentlich schon kommt. Weil ich muss auch sagen, für mich war Gefühl– also Bauchgefühl von außen– für mich war die Heiko Vogelnummer schon wieder aus erzählt. Ich hatte nicht das Gefühl, dass er nochmal den Schlüssel findet, da nochmal richtig reinzukommen, in die Ergebnisse reinzukommen. Und plötzlich passierte es dann auch noch gegen Top-Teams wie gegen Hannover. Auch das ist diese verrückte 2. Liga. Du kannst auch kein Team, was unten drin steckt, irgendwann mal abschreiben. Das funktioniert nicht. Auch deshalb nicht, weil Furtkorn hier in der ersten Halbzeit schon in der fünften Minute das 1 zu 0 macht. Und die erste Halbzeit von Furt, soweit ich das mir nachlesen konnte, denn ich konnte das Spiel nicht sehen aufgrund anderer Spiele, ging die erste Halbzeit insgesamt auch in Ordnung für Furt. So ganz gute Struktur gegen den Ball. Der KSC jetzt nicht mit den riesigen Chancen. Nur ging alles mit der 47. Minute dahin, wenn man so möchte, mit dem 1 zu 1 von Pinto Petrosa, eines der vielen Talente beim KSC, Eingewächs macht das 1 zu 1. Daraufhin entwickelt sich ein, ja, offeneres Spiel, aber so wie ich das verstanden habe, mit immer mehr Momentum seitens KSC. Und das schlägt sich dann vor allem in der Nachspielzeit nieder. Fukuda in der 90 plus 3 und Schleusen in der 90 plus 7, die dann das 2 zu 1 und 3 zu 1 machen und so die Partie drehen. Den KSC wahrscheinlich wirklich aus der Rechnung jetzt nehmen bezüglich Abschlusskampf, das haben wir schon besprochen. Aber Furt auch wieder sehr reinziehen in die Nummer und den Drive der letzten Wochen eben nicht weiterführen lassen mit 29 Punkten und dem schlechtesten Torverhältnis. Das sollte zu erwähnen sein, denn das kann am Ende ja auch quasi ein Punkt sein für dich. Steht man jetzt auf Rang 14. Tobi, wie blickst du auf das Kleblat? Wie gesagt, du hast das ja zuletzt gegen Hannover auch erlebt. Was machen die für einen Eindruck auf dich? Wie kriegst du die überhaupt zu fassen? So vom Auftreten her, von der Form her?
Ja, schon. Ich finde, man sollte auf gar keinen Fall jetzt anfangen, dieses 3-1 von Karlsruhe in irgendeiner Form überzubewerten. Denn du hast es gerade gesagt, die Tore sind quasi mit dem Abpfiff gefallen. Das tut glaube ich tabellarisch richtig, richtig böse weh, weil jetzt braucht 40 keine großen Hoffnungen mehr zu machen, Karlsruhe noch einzuholen. Also, die müssen jetzt woanders hingucken. Sollte führt, aber dann bitte auch nicht unnötig verunsichern bzw. von dem aktuellen Weg abbringen, denn der Lauf ist gut. Sie haben gegen Hannover völlig zurecht 2-1 gewonnen. Ich weiß nicht, das war ganz komisch und unangenehm, aber es war halt– oh Gott, war wir schlecht gelaunt an diesem Sonntag. Das war wirklich Wahnsinn. Die haben uns einfach 2-1 geschlagen und keiner hat es kommen sehen. Und wir haben im Hinspiel schon nur 2-2 gespielt und da waren sie, glaube ich, letzter oder keine Ahnung, was sie da in dem Moment waren, aber auch nicht viel weiter oben. Ich finde, Führt hat eine bessere Mannschaft, als es die Punkte hergeben würde. Führt hat offensichtlich ein Gegentorproblem, das hat Karlsruhe auch. Also zusammen hatten die, glaube ich, schon vor dem Spiel über 100 Gegentore generiert. Jetzt sind es dann nochmal 4 mehr geworden. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe das Spiel natürlich nicht gesehen, weil ich komischerweise in diesem anderen Stadion war, wo zeitgleich ein Derby stattgefunden hat. Habe mir dann die Zusammenfassung angeguckt und würde jetzt sagen, Führt, ähnlich wie Dresden, die sind ja nun auch wenig überraschend punktgleich, auch wenn sie 18 Tore trennen, gehört zu denen da unten, die sich im Moment nicht so viel Sorgen machen sollten. Auch da gilt, wie gesagt, der Blick zurück ist nicht der Blick nach vorne. Da müssen wir mal schauen, wie sie denn dann so was verkraften. Denn jetzt spielen sie als nächstes gegen Paderborn und dann hast du, also gehen wir mal davon aus, dass es gegen Paderborn vielleicht nicht ganz so erfolgreich läuft, aber dann hast du mit Münster natürlich das direkte Duell wieder da unten. Und so wie wir oben die ganze Zeit darüber reden, dass es 6-Punktespiele noch und nöcher gibt, gibt es die natürlich unten auch. Und das wären dann die Dinge, da kannst du noch so einen Lauf haben, wenn auf einmal Münster gegen dich dann gewinnt, dann haben die dich schon wieder eingeholt oder bist du auf einen Punkt dran. Fürth ist noch lange nicht unten raus, aber im Moment würde ich sagen, sind sie eine der Mannschaften, die besseren Eindruck hinterlassen. Einfach weil sie einfach, ich glaube, die haben einfach Spieler, die besser sind von der individuellen Klasse, als es der eine oder andere da unten zu bieten hat.
Das stimmt. Und mir würde aus vierter Sicht auch die Heimbilanz durchaus Mut geben, zumindest auch zuletzt. Da war das 2 zu 0 gegen Elbersberg, da war das 1 zu 1 gegen Schalke, 2 zu 1 gegen Bielefeld. Und du hast in den Heimspielen noch Darmstadt, aber vor allen Dingen Nürnberg und Düsseldorf. Und Düsseldorf auch am letzten Spieltag. Da kann für Düsseldorf schon alles durch sein im positiven Sinne. Für Nürnberg ist es das auch. Das sind Heimspiele. Also Franken-Dirby, wenn du das noch am 32. Spieltag gewinnst, dann würde ich mal sehen, wie du gegen Hertha und Düsseldorf einreitest. Also das sind auch noch so Faktoren, die natürlich eine riesige Rolle spielen können. Das Franken-Dirby war ja, glaube ich, auch das erste Spiel unter Heiko Vogel in der Hinrunde. Meine ich mich zu erinnern? Dieses 2 zu 2? Ich bin mir recht sicher, dass sie diese zwei Freak unentschieden gegen Nürnberg und dann Hertha hatten. Und das waren die ersten Spiele von Heiko Vogel. Aber es ist genau das, was du sagst, Tobi. Allein die individuelle Qualität mit einem Footcoy, mit einem Felix Klaus, mit einem Branimir Hürgota, der jetzt, glaube ich, zumindest, der ja auch immer irgendwie noch was im Schuh haben kann. Julian Green, der jetzt auch zurückgekommen ist, der jetzt auch sicherlich taktisch, strategisch ein großer Faktor sein kann. Ein, zwei Wintertransfers mit Letaev, den sie geholt haben, der auch noch mal einen Eindruck macht. Also, hui, ich bin, bei Viert bin ich, es ist quasi das Hannover 96 der unteren Tabellenhälfte. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich da erwarten soll. Kein Plan.
Ja, ich glaube, das, was du sagtest einleitend, Heiko Vogel-Geschichte schien für mich auch kein gutes Ende zu nehmen. Die ersten Spiele, da fing er dann nach einer Zeit auch an, die Mannschaft anzuzählen. Da dachte ich auch schon, das war ein schwieriger Move. Aber letztendlich haben sie nach dem Spiel gegen Magdeburg, das war ja alle noch in Erinnerung, haben 4 zu 5 irgendwie die Kurve gekriegt. Vielleicht auch mit ein bisschen Match-Glück, wer weiß. Und sie haben es ja verstanden, offensichtlich die Gegentorflut einzudämmen oder in Griff zu kriegen. Das sind für mich schon auch Elvedi und Will, glaube ich, mit zu nennen. Zwei eben dieser Winter-Transfers, Paul Will aus Darmstadt, der hier gerade nicht so die Chance kriegt, den Stint zu drängen. Der ist einfach als Sechster sehr ball- und passsicher. Das ist schon mal was, was dir natürlich Sicherheit geben kann. Sie wirken für mich einfach deutlich stabiler und geschlossener. Ich denke, man hat ihn auch in Karlsruhe angemerkt, dass sie mittlerweile ein gewisses Selbstverständnis auf den Platz bringen. Gleich für mich Burnic als Pressing-Opfer so ein bisschen ausgeguckt vor dem 1 zu 0, der für Herhold in die Mannschaft auf die Position gerückt ist zumindest. Und ich schaue auch nicht viele Viert-Spiele, aber mir schien es auch so, dass sie jetzt gegen KSC zumindest die Räume ein bisschen enger gestalten. Also sie stehen ein bisschen höher. Dadurch hat der Gegner, wenn er jetzt nicht den Langball sucht, auch vielleicht nicht so viele Möglichkeiten ins Spiel zu finden. Und deshalb war für mich Viert auf jeden Fall in der ersten Halbzeit der Punkt-Sieger. Und dann haben sie es jetzt hinten raus einfach verloren. Aber auch da, finde ich, sollten sie sich nicht zu sehr verunsichern lassen, sondern ihren Weg, den sie jetzt zuletzt eingeschlagen haben, fortsetzen. Da ging ja offenkundig viel auf. Und insofern auch sie sind mitten drin in der Verlosung, was man ihnen so lange Zeit nicht zugesprochen hätte. Und ja, da wird an der Stelle schon noch was gehen. Ob es reicht, werden wir sehen.
Wenn du gerade auch veränderte Defensivkonstellationen ansprichst, möchte ich nur noch hinzufügen, dass ein Faktor ja auch Silas Prüfrock ist, zweitbester Name der zweiten Liga. 21-jähriger Keeper, der in der Hinrunde zwei Spiele gemacht hat, aber seit dem 22. Spieltag im Tor steht.
Nach diesem besagten 4-5 gegen Magdeburg kam er rein. Er wurde auch in der Spieleröffnung immer wieder gesucht.
Ja, es ist ja nur 1,80 groß. Also ich kenne in den ersten zwei bis drei Ligen Deutschlands keinen Keeper, der zumindest regelmäßig im Tor steht, der kleiner wäre. Also der deutsche Jan Sommer, wenn man so möchte. Und jetzt glaube ich, ist auch für die U21 nachnominiert worden. Also geht da jetzt so langsam seinen Weg und ist Teil dieses Verbundes, die diese Gegentorflut ein Stück weit aufgehalten haben. Wie gesagt, manchmal bricht es noch so durch, aber insgesamt ist das schon deutlich stabiler geworden. Und auch deswegen kann 40 berechtigte Hoffnung machen, dass es reichen könnte zumindest. Denn das, muss ich sagen, war für mich zwischenzeitlich auch so nicht mehr möglich. So, wir kommen zum nächsten Spiel. Wir kommen zum nächsten Abschüßkandidaten. Und das ist Fortuna Düsseldorf. Gemessen an der Zeit, würde ich sagen, halte ich da mal kurz mein Monolog, weil ich sie über 90 Minuten jetzt gesehen habe. Und dann kommen wir zu zwei Partien, wo jeweils zwei Teams beteiligt waren, die nach unten gucken müssen und die noch ein bisschen mehr Raum bekommen sollten. Wenn ihr aber ganz dringende Einwürfe habt dazu, dann schießt natürlich raus. Das steht völlig außer Frage. Denn Fortuna Düsseldorf verliert am Sonntagnachmittag mit 2 zu 5 gegen Hertha BSC. Das hört sich natürlich erst mal bodenlos an und ist es in einer Hinsicht auch. Denn Düsseldorf war in diesem Spiel– also, was mal vielleicht andersherum. Dieses Spiel war untypisch für das Kalenderjahr 2026 von Fortuna Düsseldorf, denn zuvor hat man in neun Spielen nur neun Gegentreffer kassiert. Markus Anfang hatte das Defensivproblem durchaus in den Griff bekommen oder hat es in den Griff bekommen bei Düsseldorf. Nur dieses Spiel hat selber mit den Worten gerungen. Nach der Partie war da das kaum eine und dann konnte was da passiert ist. Letztendlich muss man einfach sagen, dass da zwei Dinge aufeinander gekommen sind. Düsseldorf ist seit jeher nicht so gut darin, Konter abzusichern und Gegenpressing-Momente immer voll ins Durch zu ziehen. Und Herthas größte Stärke ist das Umschaltspiel. Das ist heute aufeinander getroffen. Und Hertha war brutalst effizient mit teilweise Traumtoren, wie dem von Martin Winkler, der den Ball da in den Winkel schlänzt. Das macht– ich kenne Martin Winkler gut, das macht er nicht jedes Spiel. Und auch Fabian Reese sah, nachdem er jetzt ein Spiel mal aussetzen musste, wegen der Sperre, der sah also gefühlt fünf Kilo leichter aus, im Sinne von der war flink, der war spritzig, der war kaum zu fassen in der ersten Halbzeit. Er hat vielleicht das beste Spiel seiner Saison gemacht. Das mag komisch klingen, aber es ist tatsächlich so. Und bei Hertha ging im Umschaltspiel alles auf. Gleichzeitig hat Düsseldorf mit auch sehr unerfahrenen Innenverteidigern teilweise auch alles falsch gemacht bei der Konterabsicherung. Da ging alles im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes auf, denn man hat die Räume für Hertha geöffnet. Ich fand es mitball okay, was Düsseldorf gemacht hat. Auch nicht die Offenbarung, aber okay. Man geht eins zu null in Führung sogar, muss dann eigentlich das 2 zu 0 hinterherlegen, trifft unter anderem die Latte, lässt das liegen. Und dann kassiert man dieses 1 zu 1 und fällt daraufhin defensiv auseinander. Nicht in der Gesamtstruktur, aber defensiv fällt man auseinander. Und dann steht es zur Halbzeit halt schon 1 zu 4. Freakiges Spiel. Wie gesagt, bei Hertha geht jeder Schuss auch so ein bisschen rein. In der zweiten Halbzeit verkürzt du noch auf 2 zu 4. Danach fehlt dir aber auch der Schlüssel und Stefan Leithil hat danach auch erklärt, ey, wir wollten das Ding über die Zeit bringen, wir wollten Düsseldorf auch nicht mehr in die Partie lassen. Da ging es jetzt uns nicht darum, das 6. und 7. zu machen. Und dadurch fehlte der Schlüssel. Am Ende machst du auf, ein Konter noch, dann steht es halt 2 zu 5 geschenkt. Deswegen sieht das Ergebnis sehr schlimm aus. Expected Goals zeigen einem auch auf, das muss so nicht ausgehen. Und deswegen ja, ein Spiel, was Düsseldorf wirklich ärgern sollte, weil du darfst dich zuhause in der Situation, in der du dich befindest, nicht so amateurhaft auskontern lassen. Du bist wirklich sehenden Auges in dieses offene Messer gelaufen. Das geht nicht. Das ist zu naiv. Das muss einen ärgern. Aber das sollte keine substanziellen Zweifel über dieses Kalenderjahr 26 legen, wie ich finde. Und ich finde, dieses Spiel muss man abhaken. Da geht im Videostudium sicherlich einiges. Du kannst da sehr klar aufzeigen, Freunde. Das geht nicht. Aber ich spreche jetzt hier auch über niemanden in den Stab, so ungefähr. Ich glaube, die Taktik kann Markus Anfang fahren. Hast jetzt eine Länderspielpause, kannst dich sammeln. Danach geht es gegen Kasaslautern, Kiel und Magdeburg. Ja, das ist dann teilweise auch nochmal deftig nach unten hin. Aber mir fällt schwer, dieses Ergebnis irgendwie zu überbewerten. Das sehe ich irgendwie nicht.
Ja, da würde ich auch gerne noch meine paar Cent dazu geben. Also für mich war Düsseldorf durchweg im Spiel. Also sie haben nach der Führung, wie du sagst, das 2 zu 0 liegen lassen. Nach dem Ausgleich haben sie auf die erneute Führung gedrängt, hatten zumindest Abschlusschancen. Nach dem Rückstand haben sie auch versucht, sofort postwenden, den Ausgleich zu erzielen. Sie haben es dann, glaube ich, manchmal im Passspiel nicht so sauber gemacht, woraufhin dann Hertha sofort zuschnappen konnte.
Das waren dann die Geschenke, die Hertha dann nutzen konnte, richtig.
Genau. Und das ist natürlich Hertha's Prime. Ja, das haben wir gegen Darmstadt auch gesehen. Das ist für mich Hertha, Berliners Sprinter-Club. Also es ist einfach phänomenal, was da im Umschaltfußball geht. Und mit Reese, der rechts wie links platziert, Flanken schießen und passen kann. Perfekt.
Brikalove an diesem Spiel auch wieder mal, hat wieder mal unter Beweis gestellt, dass er eigentlich nicht in die 2. Liga gehört.
Genau. Und zu Düsseldorf, natürlich haben sie nach wie vor Ausfälle. Das ist auch ein Teil der Wahrheit, der sie sicherlich nach wie vor limitiert. Auch das Anfang zur Pause gar nicht wechselt, kann man so deuten. Entweder war eigentlich mit der Herangehensweise des Spiels einverstanden und er hat die Sinne geschärft für das defensiv Verhalten. So ganz sicher, merke ich mir aber nicht, weil das war doch zu sehr ein Brunnen gefallenes Kind. Aber er hat nicht gewechselt, sagt vielleicht auch was über die personalen Situationen aus.
Ich glaube, Lündal kam nicht zur 2. Halbzeit direkt?
Der kam in der 2. Halbzeit, aber noch nicht zur Pause.
Okay.
Das war, ich sehe gerade 66er zusammen mit Lenz. Und schlussendlich, was aber wirklich das Heim der Suppe ist, ist auch die Offensivschwäche. 26 Tore nach 27 Spielen ist einfach arm. Und hätten sie Itten nicht, dann würde ich gern mal wissen, wie das aussieht, weil der hat bislang zweistellig getroffen, hatte in der ein oder anderen Torverbreitung auch seine Füße oder Köpfe im Spiel. Also das müssen sie schon verstehen, wenn sie vorne schon nicht viele Tore schließen, dass sie dann hinten nach Möglichkeiten die Null halten. Aber das würde mir schon ein bisschen Rätel aufgeben. Gleichwohl habe ich sie auch vor kurzem in Darmstadt gesehen, das ist jetzt kein Team, dass du da in ernsthafte Abstiegsnöte rechnen musst. Aber wenn sie sich natürlich nicht besinnen oder zu sehr in Sicherheit liegen, dann kann sie ihnen auch auf die Füße fallen. Aber für mich ist das schon ein Team, das da genug Substanz haben sollte und der eine oder andere würde auch wieder zurückkehren, um da sich fernzuhalten von einem kurzen Schlamassel. Aber die Harmlosigkeit im Angriff, die ist schon ein Faktor.
Definitiv. Das war auch teilweise einfach unvermögen, wie sich da Paulina und Co. angestellt haben. Appelkamp ohne Itten. Fehlt da einfach wirklich komplett die Qualität und Kalt-Schneuzigkeit. Aber wie gesagt, das Thema Fortuna Düsseldorf wollten wir damit einmal abschließen. Und ich würde sagen, jetzt gehen wir in den Schlussspurt, in zwei Partien, wo auch nochmal einiges drin war. Beginnend mit dem 3 zu 1 Auswärtssieg vom 1. FC Magdeburg in Münster. Münster verliert damit das erste Spiel nach dem Aus von Alexander Ende. Das Ende-Ende, nachdem es nur zu 6 gegen Dresden war, der Tropfen, der das fast zu überlaufen gebracht hatte. Und daraufhin darf jetzt wieder das altbekannte Trio rund um Schulze Marmeling übernehmen und versuchen, den Karren aus dem Dreck zu ziehen bei Münster. Ich konnte das Spiel nicht sehen und das war jetzt zu nah an der Aufnahme, am Aufnahmezeitpunkt. Deswegen, Tobi, du hast, glaube ich, die Konferenz zumindest geguckt. Kannst du mich vielleicht so ein bisschen reinholen in die Kräfteverhältnisse in diesem Spiel? Vielleicht auch mit Fokus auf Magdeburg, dass wir da den Sieger hervorstellen und danach können wir gerne auch über Münster vermehrt reden.
Jein. Also genau, ich habe es in der Konferenz gesehen und hatte ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass mir das spielt. Ich konnte es nicht so ganz greifen. Immer wenn sie da waren, passierten Sachen, die nicht zu dem passen, was bisher so war. Deshalb kann ich da gar nicht so richtig tief in die ganze Geschichte einsteigen. Vielleicht noch ergänzend zu der Schulze-Marmeling-Geschichte, fand Preuss Münsters sehr zurückgehalten. Er darf es ja nicht machen. Wenn sie es machen, müssen sie Strafe zahlen. Ich glaube, man hat da erst mal ganz kleine Brötchen gebacken, was das als längere Übergangslösung angeht. Man hat so kommuniziert, dass das erst mal für heute gilt. Dann gucken wir mal weiter. Klar, gewinnen sie das 3-1, dann ist man sicherlich auch bereit, in einen oder anderen Ärger mit dem DFB einzugehen. Jetzt guckt man halt mal so, was der Markt hergibt und ob Bielefeld schneller ist. Ich weiß nicht, wer dann am Ende wo landet. Aber von dem, was ich gesehen habe, hatte ich das Gefühl, dass Magdeburg das schon zu Recht gewonnen hat. Sie hatten mehr vom Spiel. Sie hatten die besseren Chancen. Und natürlich ist es dann insgesamt– jetzt muss ich mal ganz kurz nochmal nachgucken, dass ich die Uhrzeit nicht durcheinander habe– genau, mit dem Elfmeter kurz vor der Halbzeit machst du es dir natürlich dann auch ganz nett zurecht, wenn du schon kurz vor der Halbzeit das 1-0 schießt, zu Kowski dann noch das 2-0 nachlegt. Und dann, glaube ich, mit einem empty net goal zum 3-1 hinten raus, dass du die Pause nach 95. in den Sack zumachen kannst. Also, ich muss sagen, es passte irgendwie in die aktuelle Phase von Preußen Münster rein, die stehen jetzt ganz unten. Da ist der Trainerwechsel erstmal verpufft, beziehungsweise da es kein richtiger Wechsel war, sondern nur so eine Interims-Lösung, hat man ja die Patrone noch in der Länderspielpause. Und am Ende muss Preußen Münster, glaube ich, am glücklichsten sein, dass sie nur 3 Punkte hinter Platz 12 stehen. Auch wenn es im Moment alles sehr, sehr ungemütlich ist in Münster. Deshalb, auf gar keinen Fall werden sie abgeschrieben an dieser Stelle. Den Fehler wird hoffentlich keiner machen. Aber ich würde mir durchaus als Münster-Fan überlegen, könnte das noch mal so gut laufen, wie letzte Saison, wo wir in den letzten 3, 4 Spielen das Ding komplett auf links gedreht haben. Oder wird es dieses Mal wirklich enger und wir schaffen es dann vielleicht doch nicht.
Dann lass uns doch kurz bei Preußen Münster bleiben und dann vielleicht hinten raus über das Auswärts-Team reden, ist vielleicht dem Spielverlauf entsprechender. Ich glaube, ich fand es erst mal sehr, sehr schade. Gehen wir kurz auf diese Traineratlassung ein. Erst mal, ich finde es sehr schade, dass das mit Ende nicht ganz geklappt hat. Es war auch kein Reinfall. Es war jetzt keine Vollkatastrophe. Zwischenzeitlich hat Preußen Münster mit den besten Fußball dieser Liga gespielt. Ich finde, man hat die sehr klare Idee von Ende erkannt. Dann ist man irgendwann, vor allen Dingen zur Saison beginnt, über sehr viele Verletzte gestolpert, ist vielleicht deswegen auch nie mal in eine Serie gekommen. So, dass vielleicht mal noch mehr Selbstverständnis hätte entstehen können. Man sich ein bisschen Puffer anfrisst, wie es vielleicht zwischenzeitlich auch Bielefeld oder so getan hatte. Deswegen hast du irgendwie immer da rumgetänzelt unten im letzten Drittel. Und irgendwann fehlt aufgrund ausleibender Ergebnisse ja auch das Selbstverständnis. Das ist das Wichtigste in so einem anspruchsvollen Fußball, wo du eben nicht jeden Bein nach vorne klärst auf den langen Zielspieler. Das kannst du immer, aber diesen Kombinationsfußball zu spielen, dieses flache Spiel zu spielen, da brauchst du schon sehr viel Mut. Der hat zum Ende hin gefehlt. Das finde ich sehr schade, weil, wie gesagt, ich finde es erstmal schön, wenn Mannschaften sagen, wir wollen für einen gewissen Fußball stehen, wir entscheiden uns für die mutige Lösung. Wir bauen sogar den Kader danach um, machen das nicht halb gar. Daran ist härter, zum Beispiel in den letzten Jahren, oft gescheit, dass du gesagt hast, ja, Christian Fiel, aber Kader sagt nicht Christian Fiel. Na ja, gut, dann kannst du es auch lassen. So, und jetzt steht man da, wo man steht. Dieses Spiel, Matthias, ist vielleicht noch kein Fingerzeig in irgendeine Richtung?
Ja, also ich finde, dass schon diese Phase vor der Pause mitentscheiden war für das Spiel, weil zum einen erzielst du als Münster ein Tor, das dann aberkannt wird, weil der Eckengeber bei dem nach außen geklärten Ball mehr oder weniger auf der Auslinie steht und damit im Upside. Das war schon schwer zu verdauen, weil es erstmal gar nicht ersichtlich war, warum das bitte schön zurückgenommen werden sollte. Und direkt im Anschluss kassierst du durch einen Elfmeter das 0 zu 1. Und bis dahin hatte Magdeburg mehr vom Spiel, ohne jetzt gleich wohl super viel aus seinem Übergewicht zu machen. Und dann war das Bild in der zweiten Halbzeit ein anderes. Also ich habe es in der Konferenz geschaut, deshalb auch eher selektiv. Aber dann war es natürlich, wie es der Klassiker so ist. Du bist das Team, das in den Rückstand geraten ist. Du hast mehr Spielanteile, musst aber halt auch versuchen, aus den Spielanteilen etwas zu machen. Und das ist nicht so wirklich geglückt. Also Magdeburg oder Münster viel mehr ist im Verlauf der Saison viel zu oft in den Rückstand geraten. Also ich finde auch, sie haben ein Lob verdient, das vielleicht im Endeffekt nichts wert ist, aber eben in der zweiten Saison, die ohnehin als die schwerere gilt, nach Klassenerhalt, dann ein Spielsystem einzuführen, das auf Ballbesitz gemünzt ist, ist schon sehr mutig. Und ich finde, sie haben es oft genug bewiesen. Gerade am Ende der Hinrunde hatten sie Elbersberg dominiert und verlieren. Und es gab auch noch andere Spiele, wo ich sie besser gesehen habe. Und sie gehen dann mit Null Punkten heraus. Das heißt, sie müssen es einfach mal verstehen, diese Frühen oder die Rückstände in den Griff zu kriegen. Sprich, sie müssen mal in die Führung gehen. Und dann bin ich mal gespannt, was das mit der Mannschaft macht. Und im Endeffekt war es dann heute so, dass Magdeburg effizient war. Sie haben den Elfmeter verwandelt. Sie haben dann auch mehr oder weniger mit dem ersten Schuss in der zweiten Halbzeit dann das 2 zu 0 gemacht, der auch noch ein bisschen abgefälscht war. Also auch hier für Münster ungemein bitter.
Und das ist halt die Lebensversicherung von Tukowsky, wie Cedric Itten bei Düsseldorf. Und solche Spieler fehlen wiederum Braunschweig oder Münster.
Ja, also Tukowsky hat jetzt schon 13 Tore, glaube ich, erzielt. Und er war noch gar nicht von Anfang der Saison dabei. Also ist im Endeffekt derjenige, der Kars ersetzt hat, und zwar nahtlos. Also was die Torausbeute anbetrifft. Und Magdeburg ist ja noch ein Team, das die meisten Torschüsse abgibt, zwar nicht aus den gefährlichsten Situationen, hatten wir in einer der letzten Aufnahmen hier gehört. Nichtsdestotrotz, sie sind eine Mannschaft, die auch Dominanzfußball spielt, gleichwohl nicht zwingend in Tore ummünzt. Und daran krankt das System, obwohl sie so einen abschlussstarken Spieler haben. Also Magdeburg ist für mich eher so ein bisschen schwer zu greifen, weil sie Fußball spielen, ohne jetzt die Puntausbeute einzufahren, die sie eigentlich verdienen würden. Und dennoch haben sie einen der besten Stürmer der 2. Liga. Also es ist eigentlich so ein bisschen paradoxon. Und beide sind für mich wirklich Teams, die immer noch Kandidaten sind, losgelöst von der aktuellen Tabellensituation, die schwer gucken müssen, wie sie da unten sich rauskämpfen. Das ist mit einem, was weiß ich, 7 Punkten aus 3 Spielen schon fast getan, zumindest für den Moment. Aber die müssen es halt auch mal holen. Also sie müssen an der Stelle, muss Magdeburg es verstehen, ihr Übergewicht in Tore umzumünzen. Und Münster muss es verstehen, endlich mal nicht in den Rückstand zu geraten. Und bei Münster bin ich mir nicht so sicher, wie das verfangen wird. Das kommt natürlich auf die Trainerpersonalien an. Und sie hätten gegen Magdeburg, da war ich, zumindest hatte ich ein Auge drauf. Weil Magdeburg ja so als Mannschaft gilt, die auch bei defensiven Standards anfällig ist vor Gegentore. Und Münster hat es aber nicht verstanden, da wirklich was draus zu machen. Nach 80. Minute oder kurzer Nacht, dachte ich schon so, ah, Reimann faustet einen Eckball an die Latte. Kann passieren. Aber im Moment werden auch die Fünfer überladen, noch ein Nöcher. Und wahrscheinlich hat man es auch erkannt, dass Magdeburg da anfällig ist. Aber dennoch Münster hat es nicht verstanden. Dann noch das Spiel umzubiegen. Und ich würde sagen, ein sehr wichtiger Dreier für Magdeburg. Auf den lässt sich jetzt erst mal aufbauen. Sie müssen auch verstehen, ihre Heimschwäche abzustellen. Das war bislang ein Wunderpunkt.
Das ist ja immer wieder abstrus, diese Statistik. Die kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Ja. Und jetzt habe ich die nächsten Spiele von ihnen nicht im Blick, die wirst du gleich sagen. Aber sie müssen verstehen, ihr Übergewicht in zumindest Punktgewinne umzumünzen und zu Hause mit dem kraftvollen Support, der immer da ist, auch mehr Punkte zu sammeln.
Ja, ja. Ich habe ja schon öfter, das sieht sich ja auch so ein bisschen durchgeguckt, was macht einem denn Mut vielleicht? Ist es auch die Formstärke einzelner Spieler? Magdeburg zum Beispiel kann ja immer auch zum einen auf die individuelle Qualität eines Adek verweisen, aber eben auch jetzt auf diese absurde Stärke Zukowskis. Die kann den Unterschied machen. Dieser Punkt fehlt mir bei Münster komplett. Der, der am ehesten den Unterschied machen könnte, wäre vielleicht noch Oliver Battista Meyer.
Ja.
Und selbst der hat das auch…
Und der hat von Anfang an gespielt. Und den hat man erst mal außen vor gelassen und hat mich überrascht, aber da würde es sich was dabei gedacht haben. Er kam dann rein, auch das kann ja noch mal in dem Spiel was geben, wenn so einer, der Gefahrenmomente heraufbeschwört, von der Bank kommt. Aber ja, im Endeffekt fehlt ihnen vorne tatsächlich jemand, der verlässlich knipst. Und jemand wie Wilhelmsson, der in Darmstadt schon viele Verletzungsprobleme hatte, zieht sich leider auch in Münster fort, ist auch kein verlässlicher Garant.
Also Lukocz und Badmarsz verletzt, also wenn es irgendwelche anderen Kollegen in dem Kader gäbe, die vielleicht noch mal was machen könnten. Auch die fehlen dann auch noch. Also es kommt da dick und ja, also ich würde auch sagen, aufgrund dieser Niederlage wird wahrscheinlich noch mal ein neuer Trainer gesucht. Da gibt es Gerüchte um, ich glaube, von Markus Wörle, der bei Ulm betreut hatte bis in die 2. Liga hin. Ja, auch für sehr gute Defensive stand bei Ulm. Also das würde schon passen. Aber bei Münzer macht mir gerade nicht so viel Mut. Ich weiß zumindest nicht, woran man sich hochziehen soll. Auch wenn natürlich ungeahnt immer ein Trainerwechsel irgendwann Impuls geben kann, dann gewinnt das erste Spiel, denn stellen sich vielleicht neue Spieler hervor, die den Unterschied machen können, die man vorher vielleicht gar nicht so auf dem Schirm hatte. All das haben wir schon erlebt. Es ist nicht undenkbar, und trotzdem sehe ich bei Münster gerade nicht nur aufgrund dessen, weil sie jetzt Tabellenletzer sind. Das ist ja, wie gesagt, alles sehr eng. Einfach aufgrund der Auftritte zuletzt am schwersten, wenn man so möchte. Und in den nächsten Spielen treten sie an gegen Kiel, das ist das nächste Auswärtsspiel, und gegen Fürth. Das sind also direkt mal direkte Duelle, und danach spielst du gegen Schalke. Sie haben aber auch noch Bielefeld, Hannover, Darmstadt und Elvesberg, was ich damit sagen will. Sie spielen nur noch gegen Teams, für die es um richtig was geht. Also, du kannst jetzt nicht auf irgendeine nonchalante Spielweise eines Gegners setzen. Das wird nicht funktionieren. Magdeburg, wie gesagt, mit immens wichtigen drei Zählern, sind jetzt mit 27 Zählern auf Rang 17, aber eben mit sehr viel Tuchfühlung nach oben. Die nächsten drei Gegner sind zu Hause gegen Bochum, ein Auswärtsspiel in Paderborn und ein Heimspiel gegen Düsseldorf. Und bei Magdeburg sehe ich halt immer das Potenzial– Magdeburg ist für mich wiederum eine Mannschaft wie Fürth, wie, weiß ich nicht, wie man sie noch nennen könnte. Eine Mannschaft, die kann erstmal eigentlich jeden in dieser Liga schlagen. Das ist eben Köcher und das sollte einen Mut machen. Wenn du jetzt sogar vielleicht Spiele gewinnst, in denen nicht alles funktioniert, weil du einfach eine gewisse Effizienz an den Tag legst, dann kann das funktionieren. Dann kann das funktionieren. So, und dann sind wir beim letzten Spiel angekommen. Das letzte Spiel hat auch zwei Mannschaften betroffen, die noch um einiges spielen, auch wenn eine Mannschaft da vielleicht schon ein bisschen beruhigter ist. Das Spiel, was ich benenne, ist Bochum gegen Kiel. Das gewinnt Kiel mit 3 zu 2. Und alles, was ich mir dazu jetzt angucken und durchlesen konnte, sagt Tobi, ein Sieg der Effizienz.
Ja, und der schönen Tore. Also da muss man ja wirklich Kiel jetzt auch mal loben. Die kamen von ganz weit unten und aus ganz düsteren Zeiten. Das war die zweite Mannschaft, die ich, wenn ich nicht so regelmäßig auf die Tabelle gucke, irgendwie woanders verortet hätte.
Ja, so zu Schläfer, das stimmt schon.
Ja, Rutsch die Busch, waren sie auf einmal ganz, ganz weit da unten drin. Haben jetzt aber– und das muss man ganz klar sagen– Bochum geschlagen. Bochum die perfekte Chance genommen, sich mit Nürnberg, Karlsruhe, Lautern und Hertha in diese Fünferliga einzumuckeln, wo nichts mehr passiert. Ich glaube auch weiterhin, dass Bochum nichts passiert. Dafür haben sie genug Mannschaften nach unten im Weg. Aber für Kiel war es auf jeden Fall der viel, viel wichtigere Sieg. Die drei Punkte brauchten sie super dringend. Das 1 zu 0, das haben sie gemacht wie eine Mannschaft von ganz oben. Wie sie dann gekontert haben, zur Grundlinie durchgegangen sind, den Ball zurückgespielt haben, das sah ganz hervorragend aus. Das 3 zu 2 war ein absolutes Traumtor. Ich weiß nicht, was das war, so 20, 25 Meter. Schön reingecirkelt, das Ding. Also die haben nicht gespielt wie jemand, der eigentlich in der absoluten Abstiegsnot ist. Und Bochum hatte sich dann ja irgendwann dezimiert, waren nur noch 10 Mann. Ich glaube, das war so um die 60. Minute rum. Und dann dacht ich, da lagen sie 2 und zurück, die Bochumer. Da dachte ich, das Thema ist jetzt durch, haben aber dann noch in Unterzahl Philipp Hofmann das 2-2 gemacht. Und dann haben wir irgendwie schon verdient verloren. Also das war ein Sieg von Kiel, den sie sich erarbeitet haben, den sie clever geholt haben. Und natürlich, Tim Walther, da müssen wir drüber reden. Sonst wäre es dann auch schon wieder ungemütlich geworden. Also auf gar keinen Fall stelle ich mich hierhin und mache eine Trainer-Diskussion in Kiel auf. Aber da hätte sich bestimmt jemand gefunden, der sagt, dass das nicht so gut funktioniert hat. Also ganz, ganz wichtiges Ding für Kiel. Also wirklich, egal ob sie wieder so viele Gegentore gekriegt haben, aber sie haben jetzt erstmal ein Spiel gewonnen. Sie fahren nicht mit der ganz großen Panik zum nächsten Spiel gegen Preuß Münster. Und ich glaube, gehören definitiv zu denen, die nicht abzuschreiben sind und die die Sache da unten wieder super unterhaltsam und sehr, sehr spannend machen.
Ja, bleiben wir bei Kiel. Ich glaube, auch da wieder die Suche nach der Hoffnung ist auch da, dass der Kader ja individuell sehr gut ist. Das zeigt sich dann vielleicht auch in gewissen Toren. Der Kader ist gut. So, vielleicht nicht den klaren Unterschiedspieler. Gut, man könnte Bernardsson nennen, aber der ist diese Saison einfach nicht der aus den letzten zwei, drei Jahren. Aber im Durchschnitt ist dieser Kader einer der besseren in dieser Liga, wie ich finde. Da ist die Abstimmung vielleicht nicht gut, da gibt es gewisse Zonen im Kader, die nicht gut sind, eine gewisse Unwucht, auch fehlende Erfahrungen teilweise in Deutschland, in der 2. Liga im Abschusskampf geschenkt. Aber im Durchschnitt ist das ein talentierter Kader, der solche Spiele vielleicht mal drin hat, wo jetzt nicht alles funktioniert, wo du nicht gewinnen musst, aber du gewinnst halt, weil es reicht. Und ein unglaublich wichtiger Dreier. Kiel schiebt sich damit auf Rang 16 mit 28 Punkten, hat mit minus 8 noch eines der besseren Torverhältnisse, sagen wir mal so. Kein gutes, aber eines der besseren. Auch das kann ja Ausschlag geben am Ende. Und dementsprechend ja ein super wichtiger Sieg für Tim Walther, der erste Sieg. Es ist der erste Sieg für Kiel generell nach zuvor acht sieglosen Partien, in denen es insgesamt nur zwei Punkte gab. Das ist schon übel. Die nächsten Gegner sind Münster, Düsseldorf und Kassaslautern. Da kann man was holen mit ein bisschen mehr Selbstbewusstsein, wie ich finde. Und Matthias, du willst auch unbedingt was zu den Norddeutschen losfällen.
Also ich gehe auch nochmal auf diese Partie jetzt heute ein. Tobi hat es gesagt, die Tore waren schon sehr fein. Also während Bochum für mich so ein bisschen übereifrig und wild und mit Wucht nach vorne agierte.
Aber das ist Bochum ja permanent.
Das ist Bochum. Und da war Kiel mit den Tornschuhen fast mit der feinen Klinge unterwegs. Also gerade dieses Kontertor sehr zielstrebig, aber auch überlegt dann wiederum so ein bisschen No-Look-Pass in den Rückraum. Aber da ist dann Davidsen und Köpft ein, auch das 3 zu 2 hervorragend ausgeguckt, wie man den Ball nicht mit Wumms, sondern mit Köpfchen ins Eck schlänzt. Und das 2 zu 1 durch Haris, auch so im richtigen Moment dazwischen gespritzt, während sich die Bochumer nicht ganz einig sind oder eigentlich schon zu sicher waren. Das ist gegessen, da passiert nichts mehr. Und ein bisschen erinnerte es mich, weil es eben parallel lief von der Spiellage so her, ein bisschen an Hertha. Also Kiel hat an der Stelle einfach versucht, schnell und konsequent nach vorne zu spielen. Und Bochum hat sich mit einer gewissen Wucht nach vorne immer gearbeitet und reingeworfen, wirkte manchmal einfach auch ein bisschen zu kopflos. Aber das mag einfach der Konferenz geschuldet sein, dass ich es eben nicht durchbekommen konnte. Kiel, vielleicht hat es der eine oder andere gehört. Tim Walther sagte nach der letzten Niederlage zu Hause gegen Nürnberg, das ging 3 zu 2 von Nürnberg aus, jetzt gewinnen sie außer 3 zu 2. Da hatte Tim Walther schon nach dem Spiel gegen Nürnberg gesagt, er ist jetzt zuversichtlicher als zuvor. Da dachte ich noch so, typisch aus dem Leidenspruch.
Er hat sich schockverliebt in seine Mannschaft.
Damals hatten sie eine Chance plus, verlieren 3 zu 2, heute hatten sie eine Chance minus und gewinnen 3 zu 2. Insofern, seine Prophezeiung könnte eintreten und er ist irgendwie jemand, der Qua-Aussagen und Person die Angriffe auf sich zieht. Also das Team, glaube ich, ist hinter ihm als Schutzschirm erstmal gefordert in Ruhe, die richtigen Schlüsse zu ziehen und sein System zu veränderlichen. Deshalb, Kiel hat zu strugglen. Die wollen auch noch irgendwelche Niederlagen einfahren. Aber ich glaube schon, dass Tim Walther an der Stelle die Person ist, die sie da hinten raushält.
Ich gehe da mit tatsächlich, also ich gehe da mit. Ich finde, spannend ist so ein bisschen, wie es jetzt beim VfL Bochum weitergeht. Und damit meine ich gar nicht unbedingt bis zum Saisonende, sondern fast im Sommer, weil diese Partie mich noch mal darin bestätigt hat, dass man sich fragen muss, ist Uwe Rösler perspektivisch der Richtige? Wenn man sich das jetzt mal anguckt, man hat aus den letzten 12 Spielen zwei Siege geholt. Zwei. Das wird dadurch verschleiert, dass man super viele Unentschieden spielt und sich deswegen auch nie ganz nach unten bewegt. Und ich gehe auch davon aus, dass Bochum die Klasse hält. Davon gehe ich aus. Man hat es heute verpasst, den Klassenerhalt schon beinahe fix zu machen, wie ich finde, weil wenn du da drei Punkte holst, dann bau, das brennt nicht mehr an bei so wenig Spielen. Das glaube ich dann nicht. Aber mir fehlen– ich habe ja auch Bochum gegen Hertha noch mal gesehen, jetzt zuletzt über 90 Minuten– mir fehlen so ein bisschen Mut und Weiterentwicklung unter Uwe Rösler. Ja, da ist ganz viel Stabilisierung und das ist exakt das, was Bochum gebraucht hat. Und es ist wirklich nicht klein zu reden, wie sehr er Bochum stabilisiert hat und dann aus dem Gröbsten bis heute auch raushält. Definitiv. Aber ja, ob das über den Sommer hinaus Sinn ergibt, ich weiß es nicht. Ich will auch nicht vorgreifen. Das ist auch die ganz, eben die ganz große Frage, wo will Bochum hin? Weil im Sommer wird es so sein, dass bei Bochum sehr viele Spieler gehen, entweder aufgrund des Alters oder weil viele geliehen sind. Es wird wieder einen Umbruch geben. Genau dann kann ja wiederum Rößler gut sein, der sich an die zweite Liga gewöhnt, der da ein bisschen Härte reinbringt, ein bisschen Realismus, der sagt, ey, nur Klassenerhalt. Wir bleiben hier drin, keine Experimente. Zack, bum. Das kann für Bochum total in Ordnung sein. Das weiß ich nicht genau. Per se, glaube ich, ist Bochum ein Team, das sich zur oberen Tabellenhälfte der 2. Liga zählen möchte. Eines dieser Teams, das wahrscheinlich für sich definiert, ja, wir wollen Top 25 Deutschland sein, wie viele Teams es für sich in Anspruch nehmen. Weiß nicht, wie schnell sie da hinkommen wollen nach diesem eher Horrorjahr. Darf ich nicht vergessen, wie die Saison losging mit Dirk Duftner und Co. Aber ja, also, ich finde es ein bisschen uninspiriert, die ganze Nummer. Und das ist per se erstmal in Ordnung, wenn du einfach in der Klasse bleiben möchtest. Das wird auch reichen. Und für mich sind sie, wie gesagt, auch zu stabil, um nochmal richtig rein zu rutschen. Aber irgendwie bestätigt mich das Spiel, in meinen Zweifeln zumindest, darin, wie es für Bochum weitergeht. Man spielt jetzt noch in den nächsten drei Spielen gegen Magdeburg, Braunschweig und Dresden. Ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass du aus diesen Spielen irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, vier Punkte holst. Wäre nicht berühmt, reicht aber. Dann bist du durch und dann kannst du gucken. Aber du spielst danach eben auch noch gegen Fürth und Bielefeld, also gegen alle von unten. Du kannst es auch da, sind wir wieder bei Tobi. Man hat das in der eigenen Hand. Man darf sich über niemand beschweren, wenn das am Ende nicht reicht. Aber es wird, glaube ich, reichen. Und nur dann ist die Frage, wo will der VfL Bochum in der kommenden Saison hin?
Ja, also mich erinnert es ein bisschen an die letzte Saison von Darmstadt, auch Bundesliga-Absteiger, wohingegen natürlich Bochum eine längere Zeit als Darmstadt in der ersten Liga war. Das heißt, da waren dann doch nochmal andere Voraussetzungen vielleicht gegeben. Nichtsdestotrotz hast du einen schlechten Saisonstart, entlässt den Trainer, der Neue bringt den Turnaround. Ich glaube, die werden sich da schadlos halten. Die werden nicht wirklich tief unten reinrutschen, sondern...
Auch deswegen individuell Klasse auch wieder. Philipp Hofmann und Unijeka und Co. sind halt Spieler, die haben andere nicht.
Genau. Darmstadt hat es allerdings, wie man jetzt sieht, in der letzten Saison verstanden, Gerüst aufzubauen, auf dem sie wiederum nochmal Adaptionen machen konnten zu dieser Saison und es funktioniert. Und du hattest ja auch schon gesagt, Bochum hatte ja nochmal nachgelegt mit vielen Leihspielern. Hm, das heißt, die sind mutmaßlicher dann erst mal weg. Was wird dann? Und deshalb bin ich geneigt, dir zuzustimmen. Also deshalb ist für mich auch nicht so ganz absehbar, wo das dann hinführen wird. Diese Saison rechne ich sie unten raus. Die werden dann nicht mal reinrutschen. Und dann müssen sie einfach ihre Hausaufgaben. In der Sommerpause ist fast schon zu spät, weil jetzt beginnt ja schon die Planung bei vielen Teams oder wahrscheinlich bei allen. Deshalb müssen sie zusehen, die richtigen Schlüsse zu ziehen und auch die richtigen Leute zu gewinnen, die ihnen dann die Stabilität geben in der neuen Saison.
Absolut. Tobi, hast du noch was zum VfL zu sagen? Ansonsten würde ich hier langsam den Abbinder machen.
Ich würde tatsächlich nur ergänzen, dass sie, dadurch, dass sie 4 Jahre Bundesliga gespielt haben, Matthias hat es ja gerade gesagt, da ist natürlich dann auch finanziell noch ein bisschen was da vom Fernsehgeld. Also, klar, das, was da war, haben sie verjubelt, aber, also, ausgegeben, das wird netter formuliert, aber diese Tabelle ist ja so konstruiert, dass die in den letzten Jahren noch mit reinwirken in dein Fernsehgeld und dass sie sicherlich dann im Vergleich zu anderen Zweitligisten mehr Geld kriegen. Was sie damit am Ende machen, ob sie Verpflichtungen haben, will ich mich gar nicht einmischen, aber wenn nicht jetzt, wann dann so ein bisschen. Also, wenn man sich im ersten Jahr natürlich noch mal fangen muss, ist das eine, aber dann im zweiten Jahr, weiß ich nicht, wenn ich 4 Jahre Bundesliga gespielt habe, sollte noch meine Ambition auch sein, dass das jetzt nicht die nächsten 20 Jahre nicht mehr passiert, sondern das ist vielleicht nur ein bisschen. Liebe Grüße an alle Vereine, die sich dann irgendwann in der 2. Liga im 7. Jahr wiedergefunden haben und auch nicht wissen, wie das eigentlich so passiert ist. Deshalb sollte der Vorwärm Bochum sich einigermaßen beeilen. Darf ich, bevor du den Abbinder machst, vielleicht noch mit Hannover 96 abschließen, denn wir haben jetzt ungefähr zwei Stunden aufgenommen.
Oh nein, haben wir den Full-Circle-Moment?
Nein, ja. Ich wollte eigentlich nur mit der schmackigen Geschichte, die jetzt auch ungefähr zwei Stunden alt ist, sagen, dass natürlich in den zwei Stunden hier sehr viel bei meinem WhatsApp-Kanal passiert ist und dann eingeflogen ist, dann nach Nachrichten und Screenshots und Meinungen. Es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, das Auge nach Hannover zu richten in dieser Osterpause oder in dieser Länderspielpause kurz vor Ostern. Ich werde jetzt hier nicht die Gerüchte vorbeten, aber wenn davon auch nur die Hälfte stimmt, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Es ist wieder Hannover, wie wir es lieben. Liebe Grüße an, ich kann das alles nicht mehr. Das ist eine der Nachrichten, die ich gekriegt habe. Ich kann es auch wirklich nicht mehr. Wie kann man denn 13 Jahre später noch mal auf den gleichen Taschenspieler-Trick reinfallen? Egal. Es deuten sich Parallelen an. Ich bin sehr froh, dass ich keinen Hannover 96-Podcast mehr habe. Das an dieser Stelle noch abschließend gesagt. Ich glaube, das habe ich öfter gesagt, als ich es sollte. Na ja, egal. Das ist fürchterlich. Ganz fürchterlich.
Ja, wunderbar. Dann würde ich sagen, das ist doch der Abbinder. Dann machen wir das genau so. Mir bleibt eigentlich nur noch mal zu sagen, unterstütze diesen Podcast gerne finanziell. Wisst ihr ja. Und zum anderen kann ich sagen und ankündigen, dass natürlich wieder Spieltagsendungen zu den Männern und zu den Frauen kommen. Und hey, abonniert doch mal den Kanal fürs Tribünengespräch. Da kommt bald was, hat mir Max gesagt. Ich weiß selber noch nicht was. Ich bin genauso gespannt wie ihr, aber ich soll ankündigen, da kommt bald was. Schaltet rein, abonniert. Und ansonsten, Matthias, Tobi, vielen Dank für eure Zeit. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.